think of Party City like this balloon
from one of its stores when it ipo'd in
2015 the company was floating now not so
much
Shares are down 99 and the company has
filed for bankruptcy
Party City's downfall was caused by a
unique set of circumstances changing
consumer behaviors inflation and
ballooning helium prices
so what went wrong
Party City opened the doors to its first
store in 1989 but the Party City
Shoppers know today really started to
take shape in 2005 when it was bought by
two private Equity firms and then Years
Later by another firm they added
businesses to them they acquired other
suppliers and they also expanded the
store footprint tremendously under new
owners Party Cities party grew Revenue
increased and debt decreased plus it
gained about 90 stores
in 2015 Party City went public again
these private Equity firms were also
acquiring businesses and adding to the
company and also growing the store
footprint so all of that made it more
attractive as a public company well
Party City's share price fell after the
IPO it stayed steady until about 2019.
on an earnings call in May of that year
Party City announced about five percent
of its stores were closing how do we
have decided to close approximately 45
stores over the course of 2019. one
driving Factor declining balloon sales
metallic balloon sales had fallen 8.4
percent due to a global helium shortage
the helium shortage they say it's
getting too expensive to fill up all
those balloons helium is pretty
important for Party City because a lot
of
um the attraction of the retail chain
for customers is the balloons that you
can get the US's helium shortage wasn't
new it became a problem in the late
2000s but by 2019 it was deflating Party
City sales
helium is sourced as a byproduct from
natural gas extraction but a lack of new
natural gas infrastructure coming online
in the U.S hurt Supply
that drove up prices of the noble gas
and Party City stock fell
then in the fall of 2019 the company was
dealt an even bigger blow overall the
Halloween season was below expectations
Revenue in October a key month for the
company declined seven percent from the
year before and sales at its Halloween
Only Stores Halloween City dropped about
20 percent Party Cities faced a lot of
competition for example from Spirit
Halloween and then of course in the last
20 years consumers have been shifting
more to online shopping so that's also
hurt them in recent years the company
has faced many of the same challenges
affecting other retailers like changing
consumer habits due to the pandemic and
inflation
the pandemic led to smaller Gatherings
and less demand for Party City's
products even even though the pandemic
is coming to an end what the executives
at Party City have said is that they're
still finding that people are still
having smaller Gatherings than they used
to
so as a result sales and the company
stock price have continued to fall
then last December Party City hired
restructuring advisors to evaluate how
best to handle its lack of cash
on January 6th people familiar with the
matter said the retailer was planning to
file for bankruptcy
Party City shares dropped 57 to just 15
cents it definitely indicates that
investors think that you're probably
gonna at least file for bankruptcy and
maybe not survive at all as a company on
January 18th the company officially
filed for bankruptcy Party City said it
plans to reduce its 1.4 billion dollars
in debt and exit bankruptcy within four
months
the company is also evaluating its store
footprint including identifying
underperforming stores it's already
closed 28. Party City declined to
comment further Party City when they
come out of bankruptcy if things go
according to plan should shed a lot of
their debt and what that means is that
interest that they pay will be a lot
lower and lower than it has been for
years Party City's future success will
depend on whether the company can emerge
from bankruptcy and develop a strategy
to restart the party